[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
actualmente europa vive un nuevo pico de
contagios de kobe 19 pues la universidad
de oxford en conjunto con el laboratorio
astrazéneca está desarrollando una nueva
vacuna contra el virus la novedad se
trata de un fármaco nasal y no inyectado
el estudio clínico se encuentra en la
primera fase
ofrecemos la vacuna como un spray nasal
a un número reducido de personas se la
hemos dado a 30 hasta ahora y nos
movemos hacia otra etapa del estudio y
se la daremos a otras 12 personas y
facebook show en cualquier ensayo en
fase 1 el principal objetivo es entender
la seguridad y verificar cuidadosamente
que la vacuna sea segura para las
personas antes de progresar con
cualquier estudio más grande voto
histórico los voluntarios tienen entre
18 y 40 años y serán monitoreados
durante 4 meses uno de los puntos clave
a analizar es la respuesta inmune que se
genere específicamente en la nariz la
garganta y los pulmones algo que según
los responsables podría cambiar
significativamente tanto los
tratamientos como la transmisión del
virus
sabemos que las vacunas actuales tienen
un efecto sobre la transmisión del virus
pero no la frenan por completo
al ofrecer una vacuna nasal y crear una
respuesta inmune en la nariz se puede
reducir más efectivamente la transmisión
blades y creo que otro beneficio
importante tiene que ver con la
conveniencia y con que es una ruta
diferente en la experiencia de recibir
una vacuna en uruguay vamos ahora a
israel' los ojos del mundo están puestos
sobre iniciativas que permitan mantener
el calentamiento global en máximo 15
grados celsius desde niveles
preindustriales durante este siglo y
cada vez es más común hablar de captura
de carbono en el aire una técnica que
permite reciclar gas carbónico que ha
sido emitido y que se mantiene en el
ambiente pues una empresa emergente
israelí llamada high hopes lapse lo está
haciendo con globos aerostáticos
estamos tratando de monitorear el cambio
climático
queremos luchar usando esta tecnología
para capturar carbono directamente del
aire a grandes altitudes
lo hermoso es que capturar un gas es muy
fácil cuando está cerca de congelarse
el carbono se congela a 80 grados
celsius bajo cero y el único lugar en el
que podemos encontrar carbono a
temperatura cercana es 15 km sobre
nuestra cabeza
y
los globos que usa la empresa cuentan
con unos contenedores especiales que
permiten capturar el carbono congelado
para luego reciclar actualmente lo hacen
en una escala reducida pero ya trabajan
para fabricar globos más grandes y
esperan que en un lapso máximo de dos
años puedan desplegar globos que
remuevan una tonelada de carbono al día
por un costo menor a 100 dólares
hablamos ahora de una nueva tecnología
que están probando investigadores
británicos y se trata de drones que se
pueden controlar directamente con el
cerebro el prototipo lo maneja la
empresa ultra electronics que tomó un
dron y un sensor cerebral que ya
existían y desarrolló el software o
programa para que funcionaran juntos
el sensor busca las señales que creamos
aquí que pasan a través del globo ocular
al cerebro y a la corteza visual sobre
yo una vez que entró ahí como una señal
lo podemos tomar entendemos cómo se ve y
lo convertimos en un comando para lo que
sea que estemos tratando de controlar
solo en el experimento de la mujer mira
cuatro círculos que están en la pantalla
los dos grandes controlan el despegue y
el aterrizaje y los dos pequeños hacen
que el dron se desplace hacia la derecha
o la izquierda los responsables explican
que el principal objetivo de este tipo
de herramientas es el uso militar porque
facilitaría que los soldados tengan sus
manos libres para poder maniobrar con
más facilidad
hay varios lugares donde creemos que
esta tecnología se puede aplicar tal vez
conduciendo o dirigiendo vehículos
terrestres o no tripulados o
embarcaciones navales no tripuladas
grande causarán mandan hay huelgas shows
quizás proporcionando selección de menús
o para activar comandos dentro de una
sala de control tal vez en una central
nuclear todas esas cosas pueden
funcionar con esta tecnología en el
daily worker deschanel finalizamos en
versalles donde se llevó a cabo la
edición anual del concurso lépine que
premia a inventores franceses y que en
esta ocasión galardonó el trabajo de
omar sec un informático de 37 años que
creó jobs table una mesa con diferentes
funciones para hacer del teletrabajo
algo mucho más agradable es una mesa
baja que se convierte en una estación de
computador completa aire simplemente
llegar en la mañana con tu portátil y
cuando empiezas tu día de teletrabajo
conectas el computador con un solo cable
y tienes en la mesa todo lo que
necesitas además una posición ideal para
trabajar una posición ergonómica para
evitar dolor de espalda está hecha para
personas que tienen espacios pequeños no
tienen donde poner un escritorio en una
sala la mesa dispone de una pantalla que
puede plegarse un teclado táctil
integrado cuatro altavoces y discos
duros también integrados se transforma
en 30 segundos se puede regular la
altura y puede conectarse a todos los
ordenadores portátiles del mercado según
su creador
así llegamos al final de este espacio
pero les recordamos que pueden repetir
este y otros programas en nuestra web
france24 puntocom continúen con nosotros
que hay más aquí en france 24
ah